senator Sanders you're in the minority
but we still want to hear
no question millions rights are on the
fierce attack all of this country we
will end the absurdity of women today
making seventy-nine cents on the dollar
compared to men I was very proud to get
the endorsement of the Planned
Parenthood Action Fund because I've been
a leader on these issues what are women
missing about you I'm not asking people
to support me because I'm a woman we
need to empower everyone women and men
to make the best decisions in their
minds that they can make
all over this country we have Republican
candidates for president saying we hate
the government is the enemy when it
comes to a woman having to make a very
personal choice ah in that case my
Republican colleagues love the
government and what the government to
make that choice every woman in America
if that's not hypocrisy I don't know
what hypocrisy is